so right here in front we're going to
put on a beautiful colorful dish today
as you see right in front of you now
this has got three different aspects to
it the first element is just exactly
what you just discussed there drew this
is a sheet tray situation all we've done
is we've peeled our potatoes we have our
purple and our orange sweet potatoes
here and we've got our spices in front
of us as well now as we always do we're
going to add our liquid base to allow
the attractiveness and the stickiness of
that awesome oil to get into our our
spices so it's gonna get a nice little
you know a couple of seconds on that i
don't really measure say a couple of
seconds and then over here we have some
paprika and some garlic powder you
sprinkle that over the top
just like so and i honestly am not shy
by kind of going all out on those kind
of ingredients all right so this goes in
the oven show us that yeah so magic of
wonderful drew vision do you like see
what i did there oh i love dripping
it's the best because it's nice and
crispy
guys
they're beautiful now these wonderful
all right so whilst our awesome sheet
tray is cooling we can get stuck onto
our kale okay so kale actually goes with
you that way by turning it upside down
holding on to probably the second set
you know of of leafy edges right there
and just go right down like this
you get it nice enough like that and
then all you do
okay i'll stop it oh you guys
i love it oh dan thank you
and then all you do is that top part is
just simply
honestly just finish off itself so it
becomes a nice easy way to come together
now what we're going to do i'm just
going to move my sheet tray aside for a
second
and
we're going to scrunch our leafy
goodness together we're going to create
all these amazing layers from there
we're going to grab our knife
our knuckle of the most outer finger is
going to be our guide and all we're
going to do is roll forward
and that knuckle is just going to move
about a couple of millimeters back each
time and in doing so
we're going to have beautiful little
strands
nice
so where is my ingredients set up i'm
going to do for the actual dressing i
think we're going to dress it in the
bowl how about that so grab yourself
your bowl
uh we've got some olive oil three parts
oil to one part vinegar or acid so in
this case say we do
three seconds of olive oil twisting
around
that's probably about three seconds
right we're putting it a little bit more
but for every three of those we do one
of these so when you're at home if you
have even a shaker bottle or you want to
shake that up add some salt and pepper
even a little bit of maple or honey just
add a little bit of sweetness and that
can sit there and tenderize you can
leave in the fridge if you wanted to
honestly i have been known to have that
marinade overnight and the next day for
lunch it's even more soft and the final
piece of this colorful plate other than
the texture on top is the little dijon
a's we have down the bottom now in goes
our dijon mustard inside goes our olive
oil as well just to add a little bit of
lubricant and then we also have some
lemon zest and exactly oh and you're
already ahead of the game well i love i
saw the microplane and i'm also
such a big believer in zesting and
one of the things i think i've learned
most is how zesting is just such a
crucial important step to that freshness
and that flavor profile exactly but the
best way to get the juice out of a lemon
is to roll it now by doing that a lemon
has all these little sacks of juice
i mean i think you're good you've done
clear
we got a bleeder
sorry that's what goes on in my head
so all i've done is now we've released
the juice axe inside already so they're
already primed to release so you have a
less of a hard time squeezing the rest
out and then all you need to do is
deliver on top which we're about to
assemble ourselves so are you going to
are you going to assemble right now i am
i'm going to get really deep into
presentation right now okay i remember
last time you actually looked like yeah
this is good i'm excited what did i do
last time well you looked over at my one
you're like oh i wish i i wish i
actually presented it like that so i'm
gonna go second still though all right
let's see you're gonna do here
it's all about the spread nice gets it
down you know what's really great is
winter dryness with lemon all over your
hand that feels good
that feels real good
i feel like i'm going moundy like yeah
but this is home cooking we're not here
to like impress at 11 madison um so over
top we've got here our crispy little
almonds our pepitas as well oh wow that
is a hundred percent a mound i just did
i did a drew mound for sure and right
now you have a colorful dish that is
fantastic for your eyes your body your
mind and your taste buds
why do you have the urge to go in your
face
that's the free way that you you ate
that rainbow
[Music]